next up evany and ivory tower according
to a new suite as I like to call it
article that came out today the awesome
is president-elect average on all drop
is putting his business interests ahead
of what's best for the US which is not
cool because you're supposed to
represent the interests of the people or
person who got you elected jumped out
with the damaging Newsweek story head-on
by ignoring it and hanging out with
Kanye West at Trump Tower
now I want to play this again and I want
you to watch this and think about this
Kanye looks like an Android watch look
again put again I'm just you know what
this is Kanye West world
Kanye later tweeted that he met Trump to
talk about multicultural issues which I
believe as nearly as we could figure
that mainly involved teaching him this
handshake
[Applause]
believe this right he's just like you
just nailed that handshake so hard Trump
the writer of a Newsweek article claims
the Trump is trying to distract people
from his conflicts of interest which
seems pretty far-fetched be good wait
what were we just talking about oh you
guys Trump in your words means the next
time there's a big story wants to bury
who will president elect Trump meet with
Kurt himself in a mirror whispering what
have I become
yeah Moshe Leonard Cohen or Prince or
hopefully fortune food sir I think you
should just go for it meet with Vladimir
Putin they both take their shirts off
just Latta themselves in spray tan ride
horses into the sunset
[Applause]